I'm going to draw a molecule of benzene
and then we're going to think about if
anything interesting might happen with
that molecule so let me draw it so we
have six carbons in a ring so one two
three four five and six carbons in a
ring and what's interesting about
benzene why it's different than
cyclohexane is that it has these three
double bonds in the ring so let's say we
have these two carbons are double bonded
to each other these two carbons are
double bonded and then these two carbons
over here are double bonded and actually
I'll draw the hydrogen's here just so
that we remember that they're there but
I'll do it in a subtle color so this
carbon right here is going to be bonded
to how many hydrogen's it has one two
three valence electrons already used up
so it's going to have one bonded to one
hydrogen this one right here same thing
bonded to one hydrogen so it has four
valence electrons this one same thing I
think you see the pattern that each of
these are they have three bonds to
carbons one single bond to two carbons
and then one extra double bond and then
the fourth bond is to a hydrogen so let
me just draw all of the hydrogen's here
doing it in this dark color so we don't
have to pay too much attention to it now
this right here this is benzene and
you're going to see a lot about benzene
in the future but in this video we're
going to study or try to understand a
particularly interesting property of
benzene and that's resonance resonance
resonance and it's not a property of
just benzene it's a property of many
organic molecules but benzene is kind of
the most fun version so let's think
about what might happen with this
molecule right here so I have this
electron I have this electron let me do
that in a different color
I have this let me do it in this blue I
have this electron over here what if
this electron moved over to this carbon
over here so this carbon is still going
to have the other electron in the bond
it's just going to kind of pivot around
a little bit
so that electron moves over there now
this carbon doesn't need five electrons
so
this electron goes to that carbon right
over there now this carbon doesn't need
five electrons so that car so that
electron goes back to the original
carbon that lost that first electron so
at the end of the day everyone has kind
of broken even so this if this happened
if this happened let me if this happened
we might end up with a structure that
looks like this
and I'll draw I'll draw a two way arrow
because we can actually go in both
directions so let me draw just the
carbon chain so one carbon two carbons
three carbons four carbons five carbons
and six carbons and then over here we
had we had the double bond over here but
now it's moved over here so now the
double bond and actually let me do it in
a blue color so we see the difference so
now the double bond is over here this
blue electron has moved over there this
blue electron has moved up here actually
let me color code it so it makes it very
clear so let's say this is a green
electron now the green electron has
moved from this carbon over to that
carbon we could imagine that it's done
that then you would have this magenta
carbon with artists from a gentle
electron that was with this carbon but
now it's moved over to this carbon over
here and now the double bond has shifted
as well that's what this arrow showed
and then we have and then we have all
will stick with the blue carbon over
there that blue carbon has moved down to
the original carbon and now the double
bond has shifted over here has now
shifted over here so we essentially have
a very similar really the very similar
molecule you could this is actually just
a rotated version of that but we have
these double bonds that could keep
flipping back and forth between this
position and that position over there
they could just keep on doing it they
could just keep flipping either
backwards or forwards and the reality of
benzene is that it's actually never in
either this structure or this structure
it's always actually in something right
in between so if you're actually the
reality of benzene actually looks
something more like this and I'll just
draw it without drawing all the carbons
and the hydrogen's
so and obviously in this case let me
draw the hydrogen's here just since I
drew the hydrogen's up here this had the
hydrogen's over here don't want to
forget those if you ever forget them
they're implicit I want to draw the
hydrogen's but if we just look at the
overall ring we know that the carbons
and the hydrogen's are implicit the
actual structure of benzene is actually
in between that and that in reality you
kind of have a half double bond between
all of the carbons so the reality is is
that it looks something like this
so you have half a double bond there
half a double bond there half a double
bond over here half a double bond over
here and then half a double bond over
here and then we're almost done and then
half a double bond over here the reality
of benzene is that these electrons are
actually spinning around the whole ring
it's not flip-flopping between this
structure in this structure the actual
structure the lower energy state
structure is this right here now these
Lewis diagrams we actually haven't drawn
all the Lewis electrons but these are
considered contributing structures and
you often draw these when you're doing
reaction mechanisms but the reality is
is that residents the residents of these
positions creates the reality of benzene
is that it's actually sitting in this
intermediate position now the this
doesn't happen only with benzene another
example there's going to be many
examples but just so that we are we're
familiar with maybe two of the best
examples another example that you'll see
a lot in the context of resonance is the
carbonate ion so carbonate ion you have
a double bond to one oxygen and then you
have single bonds to two other oxygens
and those two other oxygens have extra
electrons so if I were to draw this
oxygen over here it has one it has one
two three four five six valence or
actually I should say it has seven
valence let me make it very clear so it
has one two three four five six seven
valence electrons and have one extra
electron so it has a negative charge and
the same is true for this one it has one
two three four five six seven valence
electrons one extra so it has a negative
and if you were to just look at this I
guess you could call it this this
resonance structure or this contributing
structure you'd say hey maybe this
oxygen and this oxygen here is neutral
so it has six valence electrons 1 1 2 3
4 5 6 maybe just maybe one of these
electrons can be given to the carbon and
then the carbon would lose an electron
to this guy on top so maybe you could
imagine a situation you could imagine a
situation where this electron right here
this electron right here gets given to
the carbon and when that gets given to
the carbon the carbon releases the
carbon it all happens simultaneously the
carbon releases this electron and it
goes back up to that oxygen over there
and so what's that going to look like if
that were to happen so if that were to
happen now our structure will look like
this we have a carbon now this carbon
has only has a single bond up here and
then we have our oxygen the oxygen it
had its it had its six valence electrons
1 2 3 4 5 6 valence electrons but now it
got this extra blue one and now it got
this extra blue one so now it has seven
valence electrons and it has a negative
charge now this oxygen over here gave
one of its electrons to the carbon now
it is bonded with it so now the carbon
has a double bond I like to do it in
that color has a double bond with this
oxygen down here has a it gave an
electron so now it only has six valence
electrons 1 2 3 4 5 6 and it is now
neutral and this oxygen over here
nothing really new happened to it let me
I could just copy and paste it so let me
copy and then let me paste it so this
one is just sitting right like that but
you could imagine a situation you could
imagine a situation where this this oh
this oxygen right here then all of a
sudden and it could have come from this
oxygen up here or it could come from
this oxygen right here this oxygen says
hey I have an extra electron let me give
it to the carbon and then the carbon
releases a double bond
with one of the other oxygens in this
case it would be this one so maybe let
me draw it so maybe this electron right
here gets given to the carbon forms a
double bond then the carbon can let go
of an electron and so this electron
right here goes back to this oxygen and
so what happens so that were to happen
our structure looks like this we have a
carbon bonded single bonded to an oxygen
up here that has one two three four five
six seven valence electrons that hasn't
changed in we could call it this
resonance reaction or however you want
to call it so it still has a negative
charge we have this guy down here
he took his electron back so now he has
seven valence electrons again so one two
three four five six seven valence
electrons again and I can even show the
one that he got back that one's in
purple so he now has a negative charge
and this guy now gave an electron to the
carbon so he forms a double bond a new
double bond so this guy forms a double
bond with the carbon he gave an electron
so only he he only has one two three
four five six valence electrons and is
now neutral now these these can all keep
swapping between each other you can even
go from this structure to that structure
you can actually go from any one of
these structures to any of the others
and the reality of the carbonate ion let
me write this down this is the carbonate
ion carbonate carbonate ion the reality
of it is that it's true structure is
someplace in between all of these is
someplace in between all of this so the
true structure of a carbonate ion would
look like this you would have a carbon
and you'd have three oxygens they'd have
at least one single bond with each of
those three oxygens and then you have
one third and then you have or I
actually actually I should say you have
one third as of a double bond with each
of them so we continue to make look this
this is one third of a bond this is a
one third of a bond this is non standard
notation but this is what is essentially
going one third of the time the electron
is on that bond and then the other two
three
of the time each of these oxygens have
an extra electron so that each you could
imagine almost have a negative a
negative two-thirds charge negative
two-thirds charge now people normally
draw one of these structures because
this is a nice kind of you're dealing
with whole numbers but the reality of
carbonate ions is that it's experiencing
this resonance that the electrons are
actually always floating in between
these forms actually floating across all
of these bonds and that that actually
makes this molecule more stable this is
at a lower energy state than any of
these forms and the same thing is true
with benzene this right here where we're
in between these two structures is
actually at a lower energy State a more
stable state than either of these forms